[Musique]
notre premier invité sera invité
politique ce matin c'est david cormand
bonjour bon merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous député européen ancien secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts à
mes côtés pour vous interroger pascal
jalabert jouant les braves ont jours
pascal comment vous qualifier cette
soirée pour europe ecologie les verts
david cormand vertigineuse pour faire un
petit jeu de mot non c'est c'est
évidemment une victoire inédite pour
nous on est un parti qu'avant beaucoup
semé les graines de l'écologie parfois
sous les quolibets l'a envoyé depuis
quelques semaines c'était plus vraiment
des quolibets c'était plus brutal plus
violents vis-à-vis de nous et puis et
puis hier soir des victoires qui sont
malgré tout à tempérer parce que
l'enseignement quand même de la journée
d'hier ça reste la maladie de
l'abstention et d'une démocratie qui est
quand même extrêmement on va tenir sur
cette abstention est ce que sincèrement
vous vous attendiez à de tels scores il
y avait des signaux qui montrait
notamment les résultats bord le fait
qu'on ait pu faire autant de listes on
n'avait jamais autant de listes
conduites par un écologiste ou une
écologiste depuis depuis la naissance
des vernes c'est dans la moitié des
villes de plus de 30 mille trente mille
habitants il y avait une liste conduite
par une one écologistes ça déjà c'est un
signal puis les scores du premier tour
et puis on sentait bien que les
alliances un peu de panique entre les
rues mlr dans un certain nombre de
villes montré une fébrilité et nous
pendant ce temps là on était assez de
panique dit l air et les rabats ça
ressemble un petit peu à ça c'était le
sauve-qui-peut avec l'espèce d'appel à
voter anti écolo on l'a vu à lyon
on l'a vu à strasbourg la vue
a bordeaux justement si on met de côté
strasbourg vous avec quand même le plus
souvent gagné à la tête de liste d'union
de la gauche ou même vous étiez parfois
comment montpellier en appui des
socialistes qui ont gagné donc assisté
tôt en retour de l'union de la gauche
dans laquelle vous pouvez prendre
leadership
je dirais pas ça comme ça bien sûr il ya
des fusions de listes avec les partis
avec lesquels nous sommes compatibles
mais je ne crois pas que ça soit un
retour à la gauche plurielle je pense
que ce qui a été la force propulsive de
ses victoires
c'est pas forcément le côté gauche à
l'ancienne mais il envie de renouveau
avec quelque chose de central de nouveau
qu'est l'écologie je pense que la force
propulsive de ces élections municipales
c'est la question est plus délicate où
on parle beaucoup de vague verte depuis
hier soir mais ce que vous reconnaissez
vous devez une grande partie de vos
victoires aux socialistes
ben on gagne jamais tout seul et
d'ailleurs quand le parti socialiste
était comment dire plus hégémonique
il gagnait pas tout seul non plus
l'histoire et de la politique c'est vrai
aussi à droite
c'est qu'il faut une idée forte qui
concentre le récit politique mais bien
sûr est en capacité de d'élargir au
tournant alors justement il va peut-être
falloir clarifier abandonnés surtout au
niveau national vous vous dites nous
sommes sans trop aujourd'hui l'écologie
est le thème central
alors vous êtes plus près du centre ou
alors plus près des insoumis qui au
parlement européen votre quasi jamais
comme vous vous êtes plus près de
d'écologistes à l'autrichienne
ou alors un peu plus classique c'est
plus fort que vous faut toujours
regarder le grand bain clivage gauche
droite européenne
on entendait les leaders d'europe
écologie les verts qu'il voulait
dépasser ce clivage de gauche qui doute
là j'avoue répondu clairement les
municipales vous êtes alliés quasiment
uniquement avec des partis de gauche et
europe écologie est à gauche aujourd'hui
l'écologie est centrale elle n'est pas
centriste
elle est centrale elle est pas centriste
et nous nous inscrivons dans une
histoire politique qui est plutôt du
côté progressiste et humaniste est donc
plutôt à gauche mais pourquoi j'hésite à
utiliser le mot
parce qu'aujourd'hui il est connoté d'un
certain nombre de renoncement ce qu'on
est et du parti socialiste et d'un
imaginaire politique autour de la
matrice marxiste qui est également
productiviste qui a un rapport à la
production à la consommation qui n'est
pas la nôtre
donc si on parle des valeurs de justice
sociale de de progrès sociétaux de
droits humains
bien sûr qu'on s'inscrit dans l'histoire
de la gauche mais on n'est pas
réductible à cette gauche d'inspiration
marxiste social-démocrate commune ce que
voulait c'est-à-dire qu'on trouve que
c'est mal c'est juste que nous sommes un
autre paradigme politique un paradigme
idéologique qui est incompatible avec ce
que sont devenus ce que sont les droits
est aujourd'hui qu'elle soit libéral
économiquement c'est incompatible avec
la sauvegarde de la planète qu'elles
soient conservatrice comme l air y
compris à propos de certains sujets
sociétaux ou qu'elle soit évidemment
d'extrême droite parce que c'est des
valeurs qui sont elles peuvent changer
en allemagne en autriche et en irlande
de ça fonctionne avec des parties de
l'anah vous parlez de coalition dans ces
pays là c'est les traditions politiques
très parlementaire où il ya des
coalitions majoritaires et qui vous avez
raison aujourd'hui
ce four entre la droite et les
l'écologie moi c'est pas ma came pour
vous dire les choses clairement d'abord
parce que l'histoire politique de notre
pays n'est pas la même il faut respecter
aussi les traditions parlementaires
notre pays ça que regarder avec nos
lunettes française ce qui peut se passer
en autriche en irlande
ça va lasser faut faire attention c'est
pas la même pression est par ailleurs en
autriche l'alternative c'était alliance
droite extrême droite est donc là on a
été en mesure d'impulser une orientation
moins pire j'ai envie de dire
qu'ailleurs mais en france c'est pas
comme ça qu'on raisonne pas ce qu'elle à
la présidentielle la personne qui gagne
la présidentielle a gagnent tout et tout
ça donc c'est très compliqué de nos yeux
à nous de voir ça allait on va revenir à
ces résultats des municipales peut-être
une ville c'est lille que vous avez
peut-être un cru un temps remporté 1
c'était de la gérer
entre martine aubry et stéphane baly
c'est clairement une déception pour vous
à compte tenu des résultats à la fin oui
c'est déjà incroyable d'avoir réussi à
être à la limite de la victoire on avait
cinq points de retard sur martine aubry
au premier tour et ça se finit à
dans les pc hors du trait donc oui je
suis très déçu pour vous diriger la
ville depuis 2001 avec les socialistes
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les résultats vous
regrettez de ne pas avoir réussi à faire
cette annonce il faut pas regretter les
conditions dans lesquelles martine aubry
envisage le rassemblement avec les
écologistes n'étaient pas respectueuse
des électrices et des électeurs du
premier tour qui nous avait accordé leur
confiance
donc il faut pas avoir de regrets
martine aubry a fait partie d'une
préquelle j'ai beaucoup de respect et de
considération a fait partie d'une
génération de du municipal isme
socialiste où on tolérait les verts à
côté à condition qu'ils soient
supplétifs quand ils font 10 % au
premier tour 11 % leur donne de trois
adjoints et ça va bien comme ça là les
scores du premier tour ne montraient pas
ça d'ailleurs les scores du deuxième le
démontre et elle a dit hannon moi je
veux pas partager le pouvoir en réalité
donc on a dit non si c'est dans ces
conditions là tant pis donc à l'arrêt
est là dit elle a redit hier soir elle a
fait un appel aux écologistes
elle dit qu'elle est écologiste mais que
ce qui est important pour elle c'est la
justice sociale est ce que c'est ce qui
a manqué pour faire cet accord à lille
non about car oui la justice électorale
qu'elle avait du mal à respecter non
mais j'ai même la façon de formuler ça
ça laisserait entendre que aux
socialistes la justice sociale aux verts
l'écologie
je ne crois pas que ça soit comme ça
d'ailleurs on l'a vu pas martine aubry
mais le parti socialiste au pouvoir
d'abord je n'ai pas vu l'écologie j'ai
pas vu non plus la justice aussi à
l'oralité
il n'ya pas d'écologie sans justice
sociale quand on dit je suis écologiste
il ya forcément la justice sociale on
peut pas avoir un autre rapport au monde
qui respecte la nature qui respecte
l'égalité 100 m au coeur la question de
la justice sociale
mais moi je réponds socialiste on doit
revisiter la question de la justice
sociale par rapport aux limites
planétaires
il n'y a pas un stock infinie de
richesses à disperser il ya une planète
qui a des limites physiques et donc
penser la justice sociale c'est penser
la justice et la sobriété aussi alors
vous avez obtenu des résultats
vertigineux comme vous dites dans les
grandes villes dans les métropoles
en revanche dans le tissu des bourreaux
gueule un peu plus ruraux des villes
plus petites
c'est plus compliqué pour vous est ce
que vous craignez pas que la fracture
entre les métropoles et ses territoires
un peu périphériques s'élargissent avec
d'un côté des
des électeurs métropole qui vote
écologiste qui inspira à moins de
voitures qui aspire en effet à découvrir
en salles et de l'autre et bien été
robert rico a besoin de vivre comme on a
toujours vécu
alors je crois pas d'abord comment dire
la répartition électorale que vous
décrivez est vraiment à mu ans et vous
verrez que quand on aura un peu plus de
temps pour regarder l'heure n'a regardé
c'était hier soir donc on a regardé que
les grosses villes mais il ya une
écologie des villes qui est connue qui
est identifié c'est ce que vous décrivez
il ya aussi une écologie des champs ou
dans en savoie dans la drôme et en
ardèche dans l'héroïsme de diagonale
comme ça qui par delà sa voix jusqu'au
pays basque où il ya une implantation
écologistes importants et en bretagne
par exemple on a gagné la ville d'auray
qui fait un peu moins de 20000 habitants
dans le morbihan
vous allez voir que les jours passant
vous on va repérer des petites taches
vertes
là où avant j'en avais pas forcément
vous savez l'écologie en réalité elle a
toujours marché sur ses deux pieds là et
d'ailleurs c'est pas un hasard si on a
une on est très fort électorat n'est
assez fort électoralement dans les
métropoles
on est assez critique sur la
métropolisation de la france nous on est
plutôt une vision avec une respect de
l'égalité des territoires rapport au
territoire ruraux justement pas une
métropole qui qu'on nous a promis comme
étant des métropoles qui irriguent au
tour alors qu'elle draine en réalité les
territoires autour fait si les verts
disent depuis des années l'europe des
régions c'est qu'on a un parti
fondamentalement régionaliste et
régionaliste c'est pas métropolitain
c'est vraiment la france des métropoles
c'est absurde
la france est un pays de régions ou de
36000 communes allez on va parler de la
suite la suite ça commence ce matin
emmanuel mâcon qui reçoit les membres de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
il promet des réponses fortes est ce que
ça vous rassure est ce que vous dites
il a entendu le message hier ça c'est
son problème de l'entendre au point
d'entendre la réalité c'est que quand il
a lancé la convention citoyenne qui je
trouve est un projet plutôt enfin
extraordinaire en tout cas le travail
qui a été rendue j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
remarquable sérieux et entre parenthèses
sa illustrer le fait que quand on dit
aux écologistes vous proposer des choses
mais les citoyens seront pas prêts là la
convention cités ils ont démontré qu'en
fait c'est les dirigeants qui sont pas
prêts les citoyens et les citoyennes ils
sont prêts au changement est donc là
maintenant la balle est dans le camp du
chef de l'état lors qu'est ce que vous
attendez il doit par l'esma qui enfin sa
vie scor c'est très simple il dit
prend tout et je le fais ça tient en une
phrase il convient de prendre les 149
progressiste et sa promesse quand il a
lancé la convention citoyenne et il a
dit je reprendrai sans filtre sans
filtre ne parlez pas de cigarette ou je
souhaite qu'il reprendra les
propositions sans filtre et bien qu'il
ait reprennent sans filtre c'était un
problème vous êtes d'accord avec les 149
propose 18 viola j'aimerais que ça aille
plus loin il ya des impasses sur la
question énergétique sur la question de
la fiscalité mais tout ce qu'ils ont
proposés sont des propositions solides
sérieuses argumenté qu'il faut
maintenant mettre en oeuvre enfin
franchement l'isolation des bâtiments et
des logements
ça fait dix ans qu'on entend parler de
ça tout le monde est d'accord c'est bon
pour le porte-monnaie c'est bon pour la
planète c'est bon pour l'emploi c'est
bon pour tout et on ne fait pas donc
mamour fall faire faut passer aux actes
est ce que au delà du discours de ce
matin il doit aussi entendre le message
dans le remaniement à venir en clair as
qu'il doit y avoir des écologistes au
gouvernement il n'y aura pas de élevé
dans le gouvernement
parce que ça c'est toujours non et bien
sûr ça serait incohérent avec le centre
de gravité politique
si on fait pas de l'épicerie s'il ya des
logiques politiques quand on fait de la
politique pour respecter les idées le
centre de gravité politique de la
majorité actuelle c'est pas l'écologie
c'est pas le social dont on parlait donc
ça aurait pas de sens d'aller dans ces
conditions dans ce gouvernement
emmanuel là qu'on ne peut pas faire un
tournant au vu des résultats d'hier soir
on va voir moi je n'y croyais pas j'y
crois pas trop mais après j'espère
franchement me tromper il ya très peu de
temps à agir pour si on veut infléchir
laquelle la question écologique donc
j'espère que déjà il va commencer par
reprendre les propositions de la
convention citoyenne et j'espère qu'il y
aura des inflexions mais je crois pas
que ce soit ce qui l'intéresse un
dernier mot sur ce remaniement pas
demande d'europe écologie les verts vous
ne le dites ce matin est ce que on parle
de pascal canfin qui est un écologiste
qui a été élu député européen sur la lys
la république en marche est-ce que ça
pour vous ça serait un bon signal pour
l'écologie je suis pas
j'ai pas tellement d'avis et je côtoie
pascal parce qu'enfin ou au parlement
européen parfois j'ai l'impression
qu'ils sont utilité c'est habillée en
vert des décisions qui pourraient être
plus écolo si le groupe our marche au
parlement européen votait comme nous les
écolos il ya plusieurs sur la pac
puissant exemple donc je sais pas si ça
sera en réalité une très bonne nouvelle
pour l'écologie pour rien vous cacher
mais pascal canfin par ailleurs est un
excellent technicien et pourquoi pas ce
qu'il en a envie par ailleurs vous avez
parlé de région il ya une autre campagne
qui commence à la rentrée c'est celle
des élections régionales
évidemment vous avez 30 10 yeux la
stratégie s'est elle est déjà définie
sur ab listes autonomes dans les douze
ou treize régions françaises la même
qu'aux municipales mais maintenir des
listes estampillées europe ecologie les
verts scinder pour les servir ça
dépendra métropole municipal aux
municipales c'est un dépendu des
endroits il n'y a pas de l'injonction
nationale surtout pour les élections
régionales ça serait un dock salle tant
qu en fait nos militantes et mono milito
vont construire des coalitions autour de
la question écologique
parfois il y aura tel ou tel partenaire
parfois pas j'imagine mais en fait on va
dupliquer aux régionales la stratégie
qu'on a mis en oeuvre aux municipales
sans injonction nationale sans statut
stratégie uniforme et cohérente avec le
territoire les partenaires potentiels et
c'est donc clairement des alliances avec
les socialistes avec selon les régions
sont à socialiste soit 1 écologie lui
les socialistes en tout cas
nous non il y aura des têtes de listes
élevé partout écologiste par tout ça je
pense mais avec des coalitions plus ou
moins large mais en tout cas des têtes
de liste europe écologie dans l'épreuve
des militantes et limitant kg vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure de ce front anti
écolo vous avez dit il a été parfois
brutales dans ces derniers jours est ce
que vous redoutez ce frontier colo pour
les élections à venir
je ne redoute pas par crainte électorale
je le redoute parce que ça brutalise le
débat démocratique dans notre pays qui
est déjà très brutalisés je pense qu'on
a besoin d'apaisement
on a besoin d'adoucir ce débat savait
pas dire renier les conflits qualité
mais c'est ça qui m'a déplu vous savez
la formule célèbre c'est au début ils
vous ignorent ensuite ils vous moque
ensuite ils vous combattent et à la fin
vous gagnez c'est ce cheminement qu'ont
connu les écologistes où nous étions
ignorait il ya 40 ans il ya 50 ans
moquée ensuite et très fortement
combattue c'est ce qui précède la
victoire mais ça a des conséquences sur
le climat du débat qui sont graves et
qui me dernière question rapidement
avant les régionales et une autre
élection ce sont les sénatoriales fin
septembre est ce qu'au vu des résultats
d'hier soir vous dites que les
écologistes peuvent avoir un groupe
autonome au sénat
ah bah ça sera notre objectif je
souhaite et ça serait cohérent que nous
construisions pour ces élections
sénatoriales en septembre des alliances
pour pouvoir c'est un scrutin des
sénatoriales plus forte moyenne donc
plus vous avez des listes importante
dans les départements à la liste
proportionnelle plus c'est vous avez
deux sénatrices et sénateurs
donc oui l'ambiance objectif à nouveau
résumé trouvé un groupe parlementaire en
france
l'écologiste oui je vous sais mais en
l'occurrence merci beaucoup merci à mr
mans d'avoir été avec nous